[MUSIC PLAYING]
GRACE MOLLISON:
My name is Grace.
I'm a Cloud solutions architect,
based out of the London office
if you were wondering where
my weird accent came from.
And I'm here to talk
to you about designing
and implementing disaster
recovery systems in GCP
no matter where
your production is.
So be that on GCP
itself, on-premises,
or in another cloud.
So when it comes
to the DR, there
tends to be a number of three
letter acronyms or TLAs.
So I just want to start to
go through some of those.
I would like to start by
actually distinguishing
between disaster recovery
and high availability.
Think about high availability
as being for a micro disaster.
A single web server dies
in a farm of web servers,
or a disk in a SAN.
To think of disaster recovery
would be when you actually
have to failover
to a recovery site
because you're no longer
able to serve your production
environment out of your
production environment.
So they're orthogonal,
but they are related.
HA will actually drive what
your DR scenario will look like,
particularly if you're running
your production on GCP.
RTO and RPO-- these are
obviously the three letter
acronyms that everybody knows
and will understand when it
comes to our DR. Think of RTO--
the Recovery Time Objective--
being how long will
it take you to get
your application
back up and running again.
Recovery Point Objective--
think about that
as how much data
are you actually
willing or able
to actually lose.
Think about going back
to that last backup
you took, or the backup and
the transaction log files.
So the smaller the
RTO and RPO value,
it has a asymptotic impact
on your bottom line,
i.e., it's likely to
cost more, because you're
going to have to put
build in more resilience
into your environment.
SLA and SLOs-- they're
often conflated,
but they are two
separate things.
The SLO is the
measurable component.
So here, the
measurable component
is how many bowls of cat
food has this cat got,
and obviously how often
I give them the cat food.
And the SLA is the agreement.
The SLOs feed into that SLA.
And also the RTO and RPO
values feed into the SLOs.
Now, obviously, I'm a not
great contract negotiator,
because this is going to
be one really fat cat.
[LAUGHTER]
So moving on.
So I just want to kind of get
you thinking about DR patterns
before we move on
and start actually
looking at some of the
features that can help you.
And I'm going to draw an
analogy with having a journey
and having a flat tire.
So if you're driving along
and you have a flat tire,
you have no spare, you
come to a complete halt.
You have to phone somebody up.
You have to get them
to come out to you.
They have to replace the tire.
That's a pretty cold
pattern, because you're not
ready for that scenario.
However, if you've got a
spare, yes, you need to halt,
but you've got everything
you need to actually recover
and continue on your journey.
You change the tire yourself.
You don't need to
wait for anybody else.
Then you can carry on.
And at the other
end, the hot pattern
would be the fact if you were
running on run flat tires.
Run flat tires means
if it has a puncture
you can still continue moving.
It may be a bit slower.
And obviously when you get to
the other end of your journey
you'll change it
to a proper tire.
But you're ready.
It doesn't really stop you, it
just makes you slow down a bit.
So we talked about patterns,
talked about the TLAs.
You need to do some planning.
So you need to start by
defining your recovery goals.
To think about this, think
about your actual application.
Because your application
will actually define what
those recovery goals are.
So here we've got three
different examples
of different types
of applications.
Batch processing-- that doesn't
tend to be time critical.
So you can do things-- and
this is a Dataproc one--
like take advantage
of preemptible VMs.
A preemptible VMs are
like standard VMs,
but you can get them
at a lower cost.
But we will reclaim
them up to 24 hours.
So with this sort of batch
processing architecture
you can have a mix of
standard and preemptibles.
So if the preemptible
gets reclaimed,
if you're using
checkpoints you can either
continue processing that
little bit of workload
from that point, or
you can start again.
It depends.
But the point is,
it's a fact that it's
kind of a warmish pattern,
because you can still carry on.
It slows you down--
you can carry on.
E-commerce has different
RTO and RPO values
throughout the application.
So the actual user
journey, that's hot.
It needs to be
available all the time.
If it too easy, users today have
a very short attention span,
and they will move on.
But the email that notifies them
that they've bought something,
that's not that important,
because they know they've
bought it.
Yes, they'll be expecting
an email at some point,
but not immediately.
It's decoupled.
It's fine.
And the recommendation
engine, that could actually be
out of date by a couple days.
Yeah, it's not great, but it's
not critical to the journey.
And then the other extreme,
the encoding and delivery,
everything's hot.
You need have to resilience
everywhere because people
want to watch their films.
The encodings got to
happen for the platform.
So you can see that how
looking at your application
will define your recovery goals.
So you identify the DR
patterns that are predictable.
You need to design for
end-to-end recovery, i.e.,
not just backing up,
but you need to actually
be able to go back to your
production environment
when it's up and running.
Make your tasks specific.
Saying run the recovery
scenario isn't good enough.
You need to actually
provide instructions,
because you don't
know who's going
to be there to do the recovery.
It might be somebody
who's not that familiar.
Say, log on to the
server, change directory
to the DR folder, and then
run the file helpmeplease.sh
with a command to do that.
Implement control measures-- you
don't really want a disaster,
so take advantage of the
self-healing features
within the platform, especially
if your production is on GCP.
Think HA if you can.
Support-- making sure
your communication lines
are sorted out.
Make sure you know
who to contact in GCP.
Make sure your contact
details are up to date.
And make sure internally
that the contact lines
are sorted out.
Verify your software licensing--
sometimes you're not
able to run your software
that you're running
in production
in a warm standby mode.
You need to double-check
those licenses.
So if you're using
third party packages,
really make sure that you're
running it in the correct way
that it's allowed to.
What happens if you
can't connect to GCP?
If your production
environment's down,
how are you going
to deploy if you're
deploying from production
to your DR scenario?
Implement maybe more than
one data recovery path.
Think about different
ways of [INAUDIBLE] how
you're going to connect to GCP
in the event of a disaster.
Test your plan regularly.
You can use things
like Deployment Manager
to bring up [INAUDIBLE] your
environment and bring it down.
It's something that
makes DR in the Cloud
so much more
compelling, because it's
just so much easier to do this.
Security and your DR plan--
you need to maintain
permission consistency
between your on-prem and GCP.
You've set up controls
on-prem or in another cloud,
and you need to mirror
that when you failover.
The permissions
you've put in place
shouldn't be forgotten about.
Make sure your users can
log into the DR environment.
Don't expect them to be able
to log into the DR environment
for the first time when
you have a disaster.
Practice.
Get them to understand
what they need to do.
Train them to use
the DR environment.
Things will be different,
particularly if it's
on-prem and going to GCP.
If it's within GCP and
they're used to that,
then obviously it's
not a big deal.
But if they're used to logging
in to their on-prem stuff,
you need to think about how you
get them to log on elsewhere.
Mirror your security
controls in GCP.
So if you classify
your data and you've
got particular controls around
that, mirror that in GCP.
So you need to understand
how to map your security
controls to using the
things like IAM in GCP.
And manage your
secrets properly.
Configuration files-- if you're
running the downloaded service
accounts keys, manage
those properly as well--
use encryption and
things like that.
So now, I'm going to
just go through and start
talking to you about
the DR building blocks.
And these are features of these
platforms that lend themselves
to DR and HA.
Stackdriver-- often the
first sign of a problem
is with your monitors and logs.
So Stackdriver works
across AWS and GCP--
uptime monitors, alerts,
log in and error reporting.
I'll come back to Cloud Storage,
we'll dig into that a bit
[? easy. ?] But it's an object
store for things that backups,
data files.
Cloud DNS, it allows you
to programmatically change
DNS values.
So in the event
of a failover you
can get it to automatically with
an automated failover script
change the [INAUDIBLE]
records to point elsewhere.
So Cloud Storage has a
number of storage classes.
Nearline and Coldline
are particularly
suited for DR scenarios.
Cloud load balancing--
so a very common pattern
is to have a single IP address
that fronts either a single
serving instance or
multiple instances.
So cloud load balancing
gives you a single anycast IP
address.
It tends to be integrated
with managed instance groups.
Managed instance
groups allow you
to scale up and down identically
configured out instances.
And so, therefore it's only a
single IP address, or you can
have it so it only runs up a--
sorry, a single
serving application
is you can have
it set so it only
serves one instance at a time.
And if that instance has
a problem, replace it,
but it has exactly
the same IP address.
So Compute Engine,
again, as you'd expect,
I'll come back to that,
because it's the workhorse.
That and Cloud
Storage tends to be
the workhorse for DR. Kubernetes
Engine, which is our managed
Kubernetes service.
And you've probably heard
a lot about Kubernetes
over this event, so I'm
not going to say too much.
But basically, it allows you
to have the same workload
on multiple platforms.
Cloud Deployment Manager is
kind of actually a key feature.
This allows you to create
repeatable, consistent
environments.
So you can define your
recovery environment
in Deployment Manager.
And when there's a disaster,
you can bring it up.
Also, when you want to test, you
can bring it up and bring down,
because you only pay
for what you use.
So test, test, test.
So let's have a look at some
of the components of Compute
Engine.
So when you start
up an instance,
you start from what's
called an image.
So this image can
be fully baked.
So where it's got
everything on, it
has less external dependencies.
So maybe for your web servers,
that's kind of a good example.
They have fast boot times.
The trade-off is that that
is your version control.
So therefore,
you're going to have
to manage more of those images.
At the other end, you can start
off from of the public images
and then you layer
everything on top.
So there's more dependencies,
it has a slower boot time.
And then there's
the middle ground
where you might have all
your applications done,
and then you only actually
load up the updated files as
and when needed.
Depending on what that
instance is doing,
depends on which of
those you'll choose.
So a database probably doesn't
need to be fully baked.
You probably set it up and
then you just do upgrades.
Persistent disk--
so persistent disks
are block storage that
are attached to instances.
Two types-- standard
and regional.
So standard zone, also it
will exist in one zone.
Regional uses twice
as much storage
because there's
synchronous replication
across two zones in a region.
You need to set the permissions.
You need to grant the
permissions to attach these two
instances.
You can set the auto delete
flag on the disk to [INAUDIBLE]..
Sorry.
So that means when the instance
is destroyed, that disk
will continue to live on.
So you can attach
another instance
to that disk that's there.
And also, don't forget
to mount the disk
from within the instance.
So at this point,
you're probably
fed up with hearing
me talk for so long.
I'm now going to invite up
Chris from CloudEndure, who's
hopefully going to give you a
demo of how they can actually
help you with your DR scenario.
Thanks, Chris.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS FRANCO: --get those up.
But essentially, CloudEndure
was founded in 2012.
Is it on here, guys?
GRACE MOLLISON: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS FRANCO: Oh, beautiful.
2012, out of Tel Aviv by four
Israelis who were essentially
serial entrepreneurs.
Since then, we've grown
to four different offices,
three here in North America--
Boston, New York,
and Los Angeles.
We started with $18
million in funding.
That was just our
first and only round
of funding by strategic
investors and obviously
notable venture capital firms.
As you can see, some
of these investors
actually have disaster recovery
or backup products built-in,
so it's interesting
to note those.
I'm not big on logo
dropping, obviously,
but it is nice to look at the
ecosystem of our customers
and channel partners--
the diversity of it,
the size, and obviously
the different verticals.
I think that what this speaks
to is our flexibility in terms
of working with organizations
of different sizes,
and scopes, and focuses.
And we also pay close attention
to our channel partners
to make sure they have all
the tools available to them
to deliver a valuable
product to their customers.
So CloudEndure, essentially,
is a three-legged monster
in terms of solution use cases.
However, the underlying
technology is identical.
It's exactly the same
with just a couple
of different variations in
terms of workflow or executions.
From a diversity
standpoint with cloud,
we want to make sure that
we are selling diversity
and redundancy-- that
we have a diverse group
of different cloud
providers in our arsenal.
So we work, obviously,
closely with GCP
and the other public
cloud providers out there,
so that we allow
diversity across clouds
and within clouds.
So how does it work?
The technology from a
very granular fundamental
standpoint--
these steps are what we're
going to ask you to do,
and what the executions are
on our customers end, which
is install an agent initially.
It's an OS-based, very
lightweight kernel agent
that we install on each
machine, whether it
be virtual, physical, in
the cloud, or on-prem.
What that agent's going to do
is connect with our management
console, where,
within the console,
you're able to configure a
blueprint which essentially
defines the resources
within GCP that are required
to then spin-up those
target instances
and make them available
for production.
As Grace was saying,
test, test, test.
One big value prop
for CloudEndure
is our ability to
test at any frequency
that our customers would like.
They can do it on a Friday
afternoon before happy hour.
They can do it weekly,
monthly, bi-annually.
I know that's part of
most DR planning, so it's
important to
understand that you can
test by the click of a button
whenever it's required.
And then, once the
testing is completed,
we want to do it at
the very beginning
of the implementation, and then
obviously always and often.
But at that point,
we're able to failover
and we have those
workloads available
no matter what in GCP
come time for a failure
or to run these drills.
So here's kind of a high level
overview of the architecture.
And I think what's
important to note
is-- on the left side,
what you're going to see
is your source infrastructure.
So whether that be on-prem
data center, whether that
be a GCP production environment
in east, or west, or central.
So you have, obviously,
your machines working here.
We're going to deploy these
agents on any Windows or Linux
workload or machine with all
of the volumes attached to it.
It's going to identify itself
up to our management console,
which you see up top there.
What that console is going to
have is obviously the blueprint
piece.
But all it really takes
is metadata, so the size
and quantity of those disks.
What we're then going to
do through that management
console, is CloudEndure is
going to manage and orchestrate
our staging area--
the middle piece.
And essentially, all
that is is low cost, low
compute resources.
I believe it's an n1 small or
n1 standard that we provision
for the replication servers.
And those servers are just
recipients for the agent
traffic that then
have, I believe,
15 to 1 ratio from replication
server to volumes attached.
And that's where you
data is going to sit.
So at this point you kind of
ignore the far right target
network, because this
is kind of business
as usual in terms of
our disaster recovery.
You're going to see a
total cost of ownership
reduction of typically about 80%
versus legacy DR architectures.
So then when we actually
need to run a test,
or when we need to failover
in the case of disaster,
CloudEndure is going to
automatically orchestrate
all the necessary resources and
spin-up that target environment
in production with subsecond
RPOs and RTO of minutes.
When you're done, we failback.
We just switch the
architecture around.
Source becomes target,
target becomes source.
You can failback whether it
be deltas or full bare metal
and then we just turn
down that second instance
so you don't have to essentially
pay for it on an ongoing basis.
OK, pop into here,
into the demo.
So what you see
here, essentially,
is the management console.
It's very simplistic.
A lot of CloudEndure,
a lot of our approach
has always been simplicity.
So to kind of dig into
this for the sake of time,
we have this list of
machines, an application
server on the front-end
that essentially
is running a WordPress
blog, and a MySQL database
on the back-end.
You see here on the
replication process,
this is the stage that it's in.
So it's in CDP mode.
So you're having
a real-time copy
residing in that low
cost staging area.
Dig into this a little bit--
and this is essentially that
metadata I was talking about.
This is the only data
that CloudEndure is ever
going to take, or look
at, or have access to.
We don't ever look at the
data, have access to the data
within those workloads.
So let's go ahead and pop
over here to our WordPress.
This is not the WordPress.
This is going to be interesting.
This is the site,
but not the Press.
So let me figure out
how to pull this up.
Essentially, what we'll do is,
we'll see it in job progress--
I want to make sure we
don't run over time here.
But this is our WordPress that
we would be typically updating.
So I would put on there
whatever time it is--
4:56 PM, and then I
would go into here,
select these two instances,
and launch these machines.
You have two options--
tests and recovery.
The only difference here is that
with recovery it's essentially
going to prepare those instances
for a failback scenario
as well.
So we're going to
run these tests.
It's going to make
sure I want to do it.
Here you have all your RPOs.
So these are the
different recovery points
that you have available to you.
So essentially, it's every
10 minutes for an hour,
every hour for a day,
every day for a month.
And our new release will be
having customizable RPOs--
recovery points.
Continue a test.
So you see up top here, these
machines have been launched,
and the job progress will
provide more details.
So while we're waiting
for these to launch,
we'll kind take a
look at this progress.
The job has started
and we're waiting
for the latest snapshots.
So right now what that's
doing is provisioning
all of those resources
within that GCP environment,
it's orchestrating all the
necessary production resources,
and converting, with our
automated machine conversion,
any unlike source
infrastructure into something
that's workable in GCP.
So if you have an on-prem
environment that's a little bit
legacy, like a server
2008 or something,
and we need to convert some of
those hypervisors or workloads
into something different
within the cloud within GCP,
then they'll
convert that for you
all automatically
on the back-end.
So let's drill down into
these machines one more
time and show you a little
bit about the blueprint
that I was speaking of.
So within these
blueprints this is
where we are
defining, essentially,
those resources
that are required.
It's just machine name,
quantity, size of the disk,
essentially, what we
want to run those on.
So right here we have
an and n1 standard,
but, obviously, there's
different variations
depending on the
complexities, the size,
and different variations
of your source workload.
You can customize the
name of these servers.
So different projects or
different SQL databases,
it might be 10, 15, 5,000
that you're managing.
So in here you can
customize those.
We define a subnet.
So essentially it's
a private network
for the exclusive use of
CloudEndure in this replication
process.
Private IP and public IPs
as well, the disks required.
On the network side you have the
ability to throttle bandwidth.
So during the initial
sync, obviously,
is when we're going to utilize
those resources the most.
But after that, if we
wanted to just make sure
that production is never
interrupted from a bandwidth
perspective, you can
throttle this up and down
depending on needs.
But typically, the
default is just fine.
The dashboard, essentially, is a
high level overview of licenses
you have allocated to
your pool of licenses,
what's in initial sync mode--
so that initial seeding of the
data into the low cost staging
area--
and what's ready, which
means it's in full CDP mode
and you have a
real-time copy waiting
for failover-- waiting for
that execution to take place.
Typically, between
these two phases,
it pops into the
require attention.
So after the initial
sync, it will
say require
attention, which just
means we highly recommend that
you do some testing on this.
Again, we're always going
to promote test, test,
test as well.
The audit log essentially
is an overview
of all the different
transactions
that have taken place.
We've run the demo a few
times the last couple of days.
It also shows test launch.
You can delete the replication.
So all of this is kind of
taking place in the back-end,
giving you a bit of an audit
trail for compliance reasons
or for internal best practices.
On the setup and info,
you have the machines
associated with this project,
your GCP credentials.
These credentials,
again, go back
to that kind of defining
where we're going
and what we're doing with it,
replication settings in terms
of what your source is
and what your target is.
So in this case,
we have, I believe,
it's AWS is our demo
environment to Google Central--
replication servers,
hosts names, et cetera.
So everything that's sitting on
that source from the OS level
from, the disk level, is
being replicated fully.
Every setting, every
security group, subnets,
disk sizes-- all of that
is completely, again,
in real-time at block level,
replication taking place,
ready to be restored based
on that blueprint definition.
And some of these are
just other settings
that I can go into-- email
notifications and whatnot.
So to add a new
machine we go up here
to how to add new machines.
It's as simple as
deploying an agent.
That agent immediately syncs
with the GCP cloud environment
that you defined and
goes into sync mode
without any further
action required.
Let's go back to the machines.
And you'll always, again, see
which phase they're in here--
and when they were tested.
It looks like we actually
launched our SQL so far,
and our target machines
have been launched.
So you can see that in here we
have an RTO of 7:56 PM to 8:01.
So about four minutes and
we have fully functional,
what would be a
WordPress with an update
to it, executed and
in failover mode.
So from here, again,
until your source machines
are back up and running, we
can failback at any given time
by flipping that architecture.
And then the best part about
it, is we select these machines
and we delete these
target instances saving us
all the money associated with
GCP resources being consumed.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GRACE MOLLISON: [INAUDIBLE]
mostly with this.
OK, so continuing on.
We're going to be
tight for time.
So first thing that you need
to think about when connecting
to GCP is connectivity.
You need to think about
what's going to be
passed across your bandwidth.
You need to think about what
else is sharing that bandwidth.
Typically, we see one of
the flavors of Interconnect.
So this helps.
This is important, because
it helps you get over
the variances of transferring
stuff across the internet.
You've got more
control over the hops.
So once you've decided on
how you're going to connect,
you then need to think about
how you do the transfer.
Initially, you tend to
seed your environment.
So you have a large
amount of data.
So use something like that
the Google Transfer Appliance
and then once you've got
that seeded and you've got
your warm standby or whatever
on GCP, you can then use, maybe,
something like gsutil or
the Google Transfer Service
to move over
incremental updates.
So there's typically data
involved when you do a DR.
So I tend to put it into two
lots, what I call data backups
and database backups.
Data backups are just
essentially a discrete amount
of data copied from one place
to another place, so typically
Cloud Storage.
Whereas database backups
tend to be more complicated,
because you're copying over
the backup of your database
using the system that your
database engine uses to create
the backup, and also
the transaction log
files, particularly for
relational databases.
Plus you've got to make
sure that in GCP you've
got the ability to run the
correct version of the database
server so that you
can actually restore
the backups and the
transaction log file.
So it tends to be
more complicated.
And the key thing there is
the recovery point objective.
So you've got to make
sure that you're also
thinking about getting
your transaction log
files over a good cadence.
A typical pattern for DR is
a tiered storage pattern.
So traditionally,
this means tiering
data from local fast disks
to slower, cheaper disks
as you move along.
In GCP it's slightly different.
So you have the fast,
persistent disks
being the faster local
disks, and then you
tier it to Cloud Storage.
So the performance is the
same for both of those.
And you tier, but as you
don't need access to the data
as quickly, it becomes
cheaper to store
on Coldline or Nearline.
And just to show you
that the patterns are
the same whether you
do it on-prem or not,
here we have a tiered
storage pattern,
whereby you've got Cloud
Interconnect connecting
to your on-prem to GCP.
You've got your
on-premise's storage array,
and you're tiering data
off to a regional packet,
and then to a Nearline
or Coldline bucket.
You could actually
decide that you
want to change the
class of the object
when it gets to the
regional bucket.
What I find is that most people
tend to actually just want
another bucket to
do the tiering,
because it logically
just is easier to see.
So GCP has a number
of managed databases.
And they're designed
for scale and volume.
So they're designed for
managing petabytes of database.
So laws of physics,
doing backup and restores
of huge amounts of
data is just going
to take an awful long time.
So you need to think about how
you design those databases.
Maybe have tables
that are designed
so that you've
got them in dates.
So if there's a corruption
for a particular date,
you only have you have to
worry about that sliver
of your database.
These systems tend to be
replicated underneath anyway,
but we do understand that people
want a better level of comfort.
You can export things
to Cloud Storage,
or you could keep the raw files.
Maybe you only need that day's
bit of data to actually get up
and running.
So you just need to
think it through.
I would also like to call
out here Cloud Composer.
This is our manage
Apache Airflow.
Using a directed
acrylic graph it
allows you to design a flow
for moving data around.
So you can use it, and it has
operators, which are plugins,
for things like BigQuery
and Cloud Storage.
So you can use that
to move data around
from BigQuery and
Cloud Storage to get
a backup system that way.
OK, fun bit, we'll look
at some architectures.
Let's start by looking
at production on GCP.
HA first-- you need to think
about high availability when
you're designing your
application on GCP,
because they've got
these features built in--
so zones and regions.
So we've talked about
most of these briefly.
So I can whiz on.
The security controls you don't
need to worry so much about,
because you're in GCP anyway.
So you would have defined
your security controls
and they would be easy to
apply to your new environment.
Here's an interesting
DR scenario--
you're running your
web service out of GCE,
and you've also got
a static website
on Cloud Storage that's sitting
there looking interesting.
Say there's a problem with
serving your web service out
of GCE.
Then what you can do, is you
can flip Cloud DNS to point
to your static website.
If your web servers haven't
actually got that many moving
parts-- a bit JavaScript--
static website is
actually really
cost effective way of getting
something up and running.
You could, of course, do
HA web serving application.
So here we're using a
regional managed instance
groups, so there's
instances cross
all the zones in the region.
If one of the zones
has a problem,
then it will start
up an instance
so you could still have your
load in one of the other zones.
At the back-end we're
using Cloud SQL,
and it's doing
semi-asynchronous replication
to the replica in
the other zone.
When there's a problem, it
will automatically failover.
Yes, your current
connections will be lost,
but they will be reconnected.
But crucially, you're
still serving data.
I talked about the
single IP address.
This is where this
example comes In so you
have a single running
server at any one point--
typically, for a database,
maybe for an application
middleware-type service.
You've taken snapshots
of this persistent disk.
In the event of a
problem, the snapshot
creates a disk in another zone.
I could have used regional
persistent disks here as well.
So that's another alternative.
The reason you
use snapshots here
is because standard
persistent disks are zonal.
Don't get me wrong, you would
take snapshots of the regional
as well.
But the mechanism
works different.
I mentioned you could see
Deployment Manager on the list
of the building blocks here.
Deployment Manager is here
used to bootstrap the managed
instance group and also to
start up a HTTP server where
you are echoing your custom
metrics that Stackdriver
can receive.
And then that
actually kind of helps
you to realize where
there's a problem
with the actual application.
Because sometimes the
instance might be all right,
but it's the application
you're worried about.
Productions on premises--
this is all about connectivity
really, Cloud
Storage and partners.
We've got some
fantastic partners.
You've seen one.
We've got another
one coming up later
to do another demo, because
I like people to see demos.
And then there's the
security considerations.
This is something that you
need to really think through.
You need to think about
mapping your security controls
and the permissions
your users have to GCP.
So I spoke about that
in the planning stage.
Compute Engine and
Kubernetes Engine--
it tends to be the Compute I
see a lot in this environment.
Here we have a
warm standby setup.
You're running production
out of your data center.
You'll notice that we're
actually replicating data
to a database on GCP.
That instance is quite small.
It's just sized to run the
minimal to take the replicated
data.
So in the event of
a problem, Cloud DNS
points to web servers that
have been created by snapshots.
I chose snapshots here, because
if this is a fast moving
org in this example
and they're constantly
changing the web service.
So snapshots were
the quickest way.
You could also have
chosen custom images
as a way to do that.
And then, obviously,
you could also,
to take the database to
take production workload,
you can enlargen
it so it can cope
with the production workloads.
And you can have hot HA
across GCP and on-premises.
If you do this, make
sure you've got something
that is able to work
with weighted records
so you can distribute
traffic across premises.
And at this point, I would
like to introduce Brylan from
Actifio-- and let's hope the
demo gods are still with us--
who will also talk to you
about how they can help you
with your DR environment.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRYLAN ACHILLES:
Thank you very much.
So I'll start off with just a
few brief slides and then we'll
jump right into the demo
in the interest of time.
I'm from Actifio.
Actifio is a software
company started
in 2009, that was created
to really modernize
the way customers manage data.
And what our
software delivers is
what our customers is refer
to as data as a service,
allowing customers to
access the data they
need wherever they need it, for
multiple different use cases--
data protection, disaster
recovery, certainly,
but even things like test
and development, DevOps,
and analytics use cases.
Today we're going to focus
on disaster recovery in GCP.
So let's jump right into it.
The way Actifio works,
it's a little bit
different than the previous
solution that you saw.
We manage discrete
application consistent images
of different applications
in the environment.
It might be a
virtual machine, it
might be an Oracle database
on a physical server,
it might be a SQL server,
or something like that.
But all the different
workloads that we
manage, including things like
SAP HANA, everything we do
is incremental forever updates,
moving only the changes
as efficiently as you possibly
can using incremental changes
and compression to
very efficiently move
data from wherever it
is, on-prem, or maybe
another cloud, into its
destination like GCP.
So everything we do is
discrete images at consistent,
which is important for us.
But it's not real-time or CDP.
And it's going to be
job-based and RPOs
along the lines of 15
minutes is what we advertise.
And Actifio software
runs natively in GCP.
It runs on-premises.
It runs anywhere that data
is, and takes this application
consistent data and
provides access to it
wherever you'd like to use it.
And so for the DR scenario
into Google Cloud Platform,
we've really got two
different ways we can do it.
Actifio is all about
letting customers manage
their data independent of
the infrastructure involved,
whether that's on-prem or
whether that's in the cloud.
And so we've got
two ways to do this.
The first way is our
higher performance method.
And that is the customer
is going to deploy Actifio.
This is a DR to
the cloud scenario,
so the workload is on-prem
at the customer data center.
And we're going to do DR to GCP.
So the customer would deploy
an Actifio virtual appliance
in a hypervisor of
their choice on-prem.
We're going to capture those
changes incrementally forever.
We're going to provide
access to the data locally
for local recoveries.
As Grace mentioned, that's
certainly important.
You want to avoid the DR
event as long as you can.
If you can access
it locally, great.
But obviously, to
get it into GCP,
we're going to replicate
that compressed, encrypted,
incrementally forever.
So it's very, very
efficient on the WAN.
And in GCP we're
going to send that
to an instance of
Actifio software.
In this case, our virtual
appliance, which we call Sky.
It's going to be running a GCP,
it's going to receive the data,
and we're going to store those
application consistent images
in the infrastructure
of your choice.
For the highest
performance, it would
be Google Persistent Disk.
You can use a spinning disk.
You can use flash storage
or SSD if you like.
And then from there we're
going to provision the data
into existing virtual
machines or even create
a new virtual machine,
which is what we'll
show you in the demonstration.
That's the higher
performance option,
which comes with a little bit
of additional infrastructure
cost for that performance, for
the Google Persistent Disk that
goes with it, and the
compute running Actifio
software in the cloud.
We have another interesting
architecture here as well,
where we can do the same
thing without running
any compute in the cloud.
We're going to take the data
from our software on-prem
and just stick it directly
into object storage.
Object storage is
really, really cool,
not only for disaster
recovery, but also
for data protection, which is
another use case that Actifio
solves for, where we can keep
the most recent copy in object
storage.
We can keep the copy
from 30 years ago
if you want to, because it's
very, very cost effective,
just by simply incrementally
updating those blocks.
And you don't have to
run any compute in GCP,
including the Actifio software,
until the time of a disaster,
where you would spin-up
Actifio software,
point it at the object bucket--
the Nearline or
Coldline-- and we'd
be off and running
with recoveries.
So it provides a slightly
slower, lower performance
level, but still gives you that
ability to do recoveries for DR
as well as backup scenarios
in the cloud, which
is really cool.
So at this point, let's
jump to the demonstration.
If you could, please,
switch over to the laptop.
Perfect.
So this is our Actifio
user interface,
and I can try to make up
a little bit of time here.
So I'll go relatively quickly.
This interface shows the data
that we're managing on-prem
and in the cloud.
It's based on SLAs, or
Service Level Agreements.
Here you can see we're
capturing that data every eight
hours in this case.
We're keeping three
days a history
local for local
recoveries, and then we're
streaming it up into the cloud
in actually two different ways.
We're keeping the most recent
version on higher performance
disk.
And in this case, we're
also doing daily versions
for 60 days of history in
GCP on Nearline or Coldline
object storage as well.
So we've already done that.
Through the magic of
television here, I'm
jumping over to
this environment,
and I'm going to show
you a virtual machine.
This is a VMware virtual
machine on-prem called demosql1,
and I'm going to click
on access my data here.
There's all kinds of
things you can do,
but I'm keeping it
short and sweet here.
I'm going to show
you the recovery
points that we
have in the cloud.
We'll take the most recent one.
And I could present that
data into a running VM.
If I already have a
VM running in GCP,
I could simply present
the data into it
in a couple of minutes, which
would be that screen, which
I didn't mean to click.
What I wanted to do
was a different screen,
so apologies here--
go back to access.
And what I'm going to do
is recover the system.
We don't have the VM.
Let's take this
VMware VM from on-prem
that we've replicated into
GCP, and let's make it
into a GCP VM.
So I'm going to come in here.
I'm going to call
this demosql1 in GCP.
I've got some options
here, including
providing authentication
with a JSON file.
It's got the credentials
for this particular area,
and region, and zone, and
all that good stuff in GCP.
And I'm just going
to click the button.
And what this is going to
do is essentially start
a job that's going to take
the data we already have,
orchestrate with
the APIs of GCP,
and create a virtual
machine from that data that
was a VMware VM on-prem
just a few moments ago.
So I've got a little
job monitor here,
which is right on this window,
and I've got a Compute Engine
right here.
And so, what I'm going
to do is, looking at GCP,
I'm going to filter
this for demo.
And this will just take
a couple of minutes.
We basically provision
the virtual machine,
copy the system state
information onto it,
write all the Windows
registry information
and boot information,
essentially
taking a vanilla
Windows image in GCP
and turning it into your
image from the on-prem virtual
machine.
So this will just
take a few moments
to see our new virtual
machine show up.
So I will impatiently
click the Refresh button,
as you do in a
live demonstration.
There it is.
There we go.
So there's demosql1
powering on, and the process
continues from there.
In just a few moments we
have a virtual machine
running in GCP that was
on-prem in a VM or hypervisor
previously.
If you want some
more information,
we're at the booth
downstairs on the first floor
of this building.
So I will hand it back to
Grace, and thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
GRACE MOLLISON: Thank you.
So in the interest
of time I'll whiz on.
So thank you very much, again.
Production on
another cloud-- this
is all about common tooling.
So Kubernetes, and I'm
not going to add to that.
There's some great, great
talks about Kubernetes that
can do more justice than I can.
But you know you can run it
on-prem, on another cloud,
and on GCP--
various managed services.
Cloud Storage and Amazon
S3 compatibility--
you can use Boto, which
is a Python tooling that
allows you to write objects
to both Cloud Storage and S3
with the same tooling.
Again, there's
connectivity, and you
need to be able to
map the security
controls from one to the other.
So just to wrap up,
a few tips for when
you're doing DR.
Identify your RTO
values per system and
within the system.
Identify your dependencies.
They may not always be obvious.
Understand the repeatable
architecture patterns--
so like when I talk
about tiered storage,
think about how
you can apply them.
I find it helps to list out
security considerations,
permissions, as well as the
controls you need to apply.
And define how you will deploy
to your DR environment on GCP--
i.e., remember, if your
production environment isn't
available, how are you
going to get updates
to your DR environment that
may be running in production
for longer than you expect.
And test your plans regularly.
You can now.
You only pay for what you use.
You can use Deployment Manager
to treat your infrastructure
as code.
So do that.
And GCP for DR--
why?
Total cost of ownership, you
don't have to invest upfront
in mostly idle infrastructure.
It's easy to carry
out fire drills--
test, test, test.
I know I keep saying
it, but really do it.
And no matter where
your production is held,
the same approaches apply.
Obviously, there
are differences,
but it is the same approaches.
And once you start
using GCP for DR,
it does actually make
the migration path easy.
So thank you for listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]